good morning John it is song Wednesday
that's not a chord that's the cord.
This song is about my outfit.
(singing) I remember when I was a young man,
my mama took me to the store and
I was scared out of my mind as I stared at
that dressing room door I was like what
if the pants are too bright too dark
too baggy too tight too big, rock hot or too light
and Mom was like just be yourself
son. Whatever you choose will be right.
Well, it's like she knew my very soul cuz
the pants I bought that day would change
my life I left that store with a uniform
that I was wearing when I met my wife
and at my first book rock show and
when I touched my first boob and the first
time I read Thoreau. I did it all in my
t-shirt and jeans. That's right it
doesn't mean anything. People who know me
know that I try not to say too much just
with my clothes and if you wanna get to
know me man we're gonna have to talk
so that you can find out who I am.
Well jeans are pretty great they're
durable and comfortable they're pants made
out of plants so it's hard to argue they're
unethical. And a shirt say little or a lot
I'm a fan of un-ironic images of things I like
like giraffes or
YouTube friends or bands or chickens
Jesus, nerds or bikes
but if you really want to know
what I love most about this
wardrobe is that it tells you very
little about what lies beneath these
clothes. Just by looking at me you would
never know if I'm a thousandaire or a
billionaire I want to tell you with my
mouth not with the clothes I wear.
(musical interlude)
I think it's odd how when we rebel we
put on uniforms like eyeliner or fancy pants
that come factory pre-torn
It's easy to say that a guy must be a certain
way just because he dresses off beat
and a sub cultural shortcut might be
what he's going for but it's always gonna
be incomplete.
Yeah, we're never gonna know what that means
Which is why I wear a t-shirt and jeans
That's right it doesn't mean anything.
People who know me know that I try not
to say too much just with my clothes.
And if you want to get to know me man
we're gonna have to talk so that you can
find out who I am.
yeah we're gonna have
to talk to that you can find out who I am.
Oh, we're gonna have to talk to that you
can find out who I am!
John thanks for
encouraging me to make this a song video
today. It's been a long time since I've just
sat down and played my guitar for you all.
and sometimes I feel like I need to
do more fancy stuff like big music
videos or something but you know I don't
always need to do that. And thank you to
my friend Jessalyn for coming to my
rescue when I got stuck inside of those
shirts. I thought that I could just take
them off the way I put them on,
but then no.
Sometimes there will be nerdfighters
who aren't aware that I make music or
who think that I should do music on
other channels but I'm gonna do music
here when I feel like it. And if you
didn't know, I do make music. This is my
most recent album. It's called Ellen Hardcastle.
That song that I just played
isn't on it cuz i just wrote that song.
This is for sale. There's a link below.
John, thanks for presenting the annual
report of the bank of nerdfighteria so
eloquently. It's great to have the
awesome summarized. Let's keep it up.
I will see you on Wednesday
Guess who's coming to Hank games
tomorrow? That's right! Stabby! Stab!
stab! stab! stab!